hello and welcome to the 24th PHP
tutorial we're going to be building on
the last one which was string
manipulation we left off with a way to
split up strings however we want another
method to split up strings is called
exploding strings so the way that you're
going to do that is literally call
explode so let's just hop right on into
that and we're gonna say explosion
equals explode and then within explode
you say hmm it's like kind of like
flipped with the tokenize so you're
first going to say what you want to
explode by then you want to then you
want to specify what you want to explode
in this case we're gonna do string just
like the tokenize if if that's not if
that character isn't in here this can
return a false statement so eventually
you want to say if not equals false or
something that's some sort of if
statement that'll catch if you're trying
to explode by something that doesn't
exist but otherwise what we'll do now is
what this does that the tokenize isn't
doing directly is this is going to throw
it right on into an array so it explodes
it into an array so what we can do to
view that array is use our print our
function and we want to print our
explosion so now let's just go ahead and
print that and we'll refresh as you can
see it prints out the array the zeroeth
element is hey there buddy and so why
might you use this over tokenize it
really it doesn't matter because the
reason you might use an array is it's
really easy to loop through an array but
with what we just showed you before with
the tokenize you're looping through it
right like you don't necessarily have to
loop through an array in that case we
were just looping through and we were
already utilizing the looping through
part of using an array so it really
doesn't matter which one you use but
it's good to know what someone meet you
know like you can definitely explode
something and it's good to know because
that's usually the terminology someone's
going to use like okay we we wanted to
explode that document and split by
something right it's good to know what
they were meaning by the term explode so
another cool little functions built
right into PHP is the string similarity
that's pretty cool so what we're going
to do is string 2 equals hi there buddy
and what string similarity is going to
do is it's going to return a percentage
of similarity so the way that you want
to call this is just similar underscore
texts and this takes three parameters
the first parameter is one of the things
that we're going to compare the second
parameter is the next thing that we're
going to compare and the third parameter
is you know what you want to assign that
answer to so in this case we'll just
call it similarity so now we'll do pop
down here let's just echo out and let's
use the double quotes again so we can
get familiar with this similarity is
dolla sign similarity so let's save that
pop over here refresh similarity is well
apparently it's a hundred percent well
what if we do like hey there buddy how
are you
that's not generated 100 percent yeah
so now we'll come back over here refresh
still give me on a percentage did we not
add string to or something yeah we
didn't okay so let's go back to what we
had
and we'll put this back up now that
we're actually comparing two different
strings okay here we go
similarity is between these two strings
eighty-nine point six five percent so
doesn't return a nice little decimal for
us so obviously very similar strings no
doubt so what we can do is say like hey
there buddy and then we'll add this how
are you doing today save that and let's
put that up and let's see how much
similarity they have refresh and sure
enough it's it's more like 50% which
makes sense because that you know this
first half is very similar the second
half is not very similar at all so it's
a cool little function that's built like
straight up in the end of PHP that can
be useful for obviously a lot of
different things but early you know just
finding plagiarism so you know like
universities pay a lot of money for
finding plagiarism amongst bodies of
work and so it's kind of comical you
know with very little with this plus
synonym recognition boom you've got
yourself a very high paying piece of
software the there is one more way to
split strings up and that is going to be
using a peer egg split actually I'm
sorry there's like a bunch of ways to
split strings in PHP but another way to
do that is using peer egg split and then
in the parameters you specify some
things and so the first thing that you
would specify in here is what you want
to split by and then some what you want
to split by let's say you want to split
by space and then you do what you want
to do that to but the the benefit of
peer egg split is its standing for it's
a way to use regular expressions to
split strings so eventually we'll get
into that using regular expressions
because regular expressions are just a
wonderful addition to coding so we will
be getting into that but for now if
you're still looking for a way that to
split up a string and you just can't
figure it out like regular expressions
is a way to
add a little bit of logic to how you're
gonna split strings so anyway we'll get
to that eventually but I do feel like I
ought to mention that that's another way
to split up strings so if you if you're
just the impatient type then you might
want to check that out so anyway as
always thank you for watching and stay
tuned to the next video